today we're going to be talking about
what you need to know about law school
exams so you can crush your next final
so stick around and get an edge in law
school so where to begin about law
school exams well the first thing you
should know is that almost all law
school exams consist of issues spotting
essays sometimes called hypotheticals or
hypose for short sometimes you'll see
multiple-choice or term papers in
classes but in your first year of law
school they are almost always issue
spotters the first thing you'll notice
about an issue spotting exam is that it
starts with a big story a big story
where bad things happen if it were a
criminal law exam your average issue
spotting exam would consist of people
running around murdering conspiring
assaulting and worse if it was a
Property exam you'd probably have some
sort of land dispute between different
parties or restrictions on land it was a
contract exam you'd have a contract
where some people would claim it with a
contract and some people would claim as
an invalid contract there will be lots
of people doing lots of things to each
other
that came out wrong then anyway at the
end of the story there will be a prompt
the prompt usually consists of something
very vague like explaining the rights of
the various parties or what claims does
mrs. Smith have against mr. Jones
the reason is called an issue spotting
exam is that you're going to have to
cull through those facts to come up with
the issues that need to be discussed and
here is the main thing that you need to
understand an issue spotter is not about
regurgitating the law or just
regurgitating the facts in a college
essay exam you get lots of points simply
for writing down things that you
memorized so if you are taking a class
on American history and the essay asked
about the American Revolution you'd
probably get lots of points for talking
about when the important battles were
fought the causes of the Revolution the
name of the British taxes the names the
founding father is a net cetera et
cetera facts and figures don't get you
any points in law school generally
you're an aligned
the facts as a litigator would and it's
all about application you're looking for
claims and counterclaims and defenses
and counter defenses that one party can
bring against the other or that they can
use to protect against the claims of
another party an issue spotting exam is
all about the application and you have
to learn the law and then apply the
facts they're given to you in the issue
spotter to the law that you know in this
way it's kind of like a mechanical
engineering exam you can imagine that if
an engineering professor spent a
semester explaining how a car works it
would be fair game at the end to ask the
students to design a car for the final
exam it applies what they have learned
and law school exams are sort of the
same way you are applying the law to a
given set of facts memorizing the law is
of course necessary but those are the
table stakes in law school knowing the
law will get you through the door but
knowing the law alone won't even get you
a C let alone a B or an a on the test
learning how to apply the law is a skill
it takes practice but it's a skill that
can be learned what I hate is that so
many professors claim that essay writing
is an art that is incapable of being
learned in fact although they would not
admit it to you the professor has an
interest in making you think that is
some dark art that can't be learned your
professor wants you to believe that some
people have it and some people don't but
this is just nonsense no one is born
with the skills of being able to write a
law school exam that's crazy it's just a
skill and just like learning to ride a
bike or making a free throw or learning
guitar you can learn the skills that are
important for a law school essay exam
and believe me if you can learn to pass
the else acts then you can learn to
answer an issue spotting exam during
your first year they almost all tend to
be issue spotting exams but the good
news is that you can learn how
to beat those tests it's a skill it just
takes practice and overtime you'll get
better at them so don't worry if you
don't start out writing a worthy issue
spotting exam essays no one starts out
that way it just takes practice and with
practice you'll get better and if you
take practice exams you can get an edge
on everyone else in your class oh and by
the way if you want to get better grades
on your next law school final check this
out we put together a free ebook called
the ultimate guide to crushing law
school finals just click the link below
to download it'll show you exactly how
to prepare for your next final including
how to plan how to outline and how to
study for your next fine just click
below also if you liked this video
please subscribe to our Channel we come
out with new videos on how to crush law
school all the time so thanks from
everyone here at legal eagle
[Music]